[Music]
heather's in cincinnati hi heather how
are you
hi how are you better than i deserve
what's up
i wanted to call in and see i um i've
come accumulated debt over the years and
i'm over the age of 50 and i'm trying to
get financial peace but one of the
holdups of me
going through with your program is that
i just feel like it's too late in my
life to actually be able to pay off all
my debt and then
be able to accumulate enough money for
retirement
oh absolutely you're completely ancient
you're so old
there's no chance you're gonna make it
what are you talking about girl there's
nothing in our stuff told you you were
too old i'm 61 for god's sake i can
still make it that's old you're not old
i just feel like we've got i've had so
many things like just dangling on my
life with debt that i've never been able
to just get paid off and i want to get
it that's mostly off and i want to be
able to do it that's most people how
much your dad have you got how much you
um i've got about 85 and student loans
between my husband and i my husband's 68
and then i have 12 000 in irs and
um some car loans
and then we still have our car loan
financed to 15. about um i was trying to
figure that out about 24 i think
okay what's your household income no i'm
sorry it's 18 18. i'm sorry um household
income i bring in 90 my husband is
retired he's bringing in about
1500 a month plus 300 a week
for a part-time job
okay
so you bring in about 30. okay
she got like 120 to work with yo 85 12
to the irs and 18 what kind of student
loans does he have at 68 years old
um
we went through a bad time he had a
heart issue and so we ended up going um
where he had to like put him on
suspension or whatever and so they've
just been sitting out there but he went
back to school late in life he went back
around 55
to get his master's degree
what did he retire from
um facility management
okay
um any chance he could go back to work
um for two years
is he is he is he physically able
um physically
probably but just not mentally i don't
think he would mentally want to do that
but didn't ask if he wanted to i don't
care about one
i don't want to be 85 000 in debt when
i'm 68 years old and i got a 51 year old
wife i'm getting really saddled with
this mess
yeah
hey yeah heather how
i i just got to uh
you are real real close if not already
crossed over that line from being
frustrated and burned out to resentment
aren't you
well i don't know that i'm resentful
it's just i'm nervous that i've got
we've got a lot here that we need to pay
off and there's i just don't it's going
to be difficult it is but
you rolling this out and you're making
90 000 and him making 30. and him i
don't he's not gonna want to
all right
here's the deal okay you can do this on
110
and uh if we say 85 and 30
is um 120 huh 125 right
okay
so how fast you pay off 125 making 120
well if you lived on 60 000 you would do
it in two years and some change
if you live on more than that it's going
to take you three years and some change
but you're gonna have no life for the
next three years
my personal recommendation would be that
bubba go back to work during that time
whether he wants to or not for two years
and you guys clean it all up in two
years and throw fifty thousand bucks in
the bank at the end of the three you two
years he's 70 you're 53 you're debt free
with 50 grand in the bank but the faster
you do this and the more harsh
circumstances you put your life in
so that you have extra money to throw at
this
meaning harsh meaning he goes back to
work he didn't want to you guys have
absolutely no freaking life
i'm talking drop an atomic bomb on your
lifestyle don't talk to me about going
on vacation
i'm retired well kiss my butt you're
broke
okay
and so uh you know not a chance here you
got to get after this and both of you
got to get after this
and it sounds like he's
emotionally in coast mode
and you're in freak out worried mode
you're ready to go frenetic on this and
go crazy and you're afraid you're going
to drag him that's what i think i'm
hearing between the lines am i reading
that wrong
well he's agreed to do
the program with me because i did talk
to him about it he's agreed to do
whatever until he found out the program
then he was going back to work until he
found that out correct we haven't talked
about that
that probably will change things in here
well if he gets really enthused about
what this will do for you
and he wants to do this as an offer of
service to his wife
uh he'll find some energy to go do some
of these things i don't know exactly
what that is but he's got a master's
degree
and i think he's got earning potential
and you think he's got a little gas left
in the tank
and you're telling me that a lot of this
mess is his
uh or is related to him it's your all's
mess because you're married both of you
are into this but yeah that's what i
would do so i can give you great hope to
the extent that i can get both of you
enthused excited
on board
fired up so much that you're willing to
sacrifice and you put whatever you want
to put in the bucket called sacrifice
but sacrifice means the income goes up
and the
in and the outgo goes down and the
difference is thrown at this and you can
mathematically clean this up in two to
three years
prefer it to be two years with some
money in the bank at the end of the
story so hang on we're going to sign you
up for financial peace university we'll
show you couples just like you two that
have done this time and time and time
and time again just do a little
scrolling through the youtube uh
debt-free screams and you'll find some
couples just like you that are doing
this just like him just like you just
like the two of you
and you know you can pull this off but
he needs to hear your heart
on how worried you are that he's going
to die and leave you with this
because that's under all this he's
freaking you out and really it kind of
should be yeah i don't want you to be
completely freaked out but i want you to
be worried enough to do something about
it i would love to see you go to a
coffee shop by yourself and write down
what do i need right now like what what
what what do i need from my husband and
it might be that y'all never sat down
and had that directive a conversation
and i need you to plug in on this
because i need to be free from
underneath all of this debt and
i think we're getting part of the story
here dave but you got irs here this is a
big long you got heart attack heart
issues along the way there's been a lot
of stuff going on here man and so i
would love love love to see
see heather i'd love to see you write
your needs down and go sit down your
husband and sam out loud